all right welcome to the seventh and
final step of how to solve a Rubik's
Cube if you follow it along and you've
made it this far then you've done very
well so pat yourself on the back there's
only one algorithm left to know and
that's called the Alan and that is left
180 top counterclockwise back clockwise
front counter clockwise left 180 back
counter clockwise front clockwise top
counterclockwise and left 180 it's a
relatively long algorithm but it didn't
take too long for me to memorize it if
you write it down and you do it a few
times you could probably catch on to it
pretty quick too
so just be sure to pay attention while I
go through it on the actual rubik's cube
if you don't plan to write it down okay
so at this point you should have a cube
that looks like either this one or this
one this one has all four sides
basically completed as well as the
bottom two layers but in the top layer
here each side has one edge that is in
the improper position this cube on the
other hand has one side that is
completely finished of course the bottom
two layers also are done and the top
faces is complete and three of the other
sides are incomplete meaning they just
have that one top layer edge piece that
is in the wrong position okay
so what the Allen actually does is it
rotates the pieces in a counterclockwise
position so if we were going to
designate this which we have to the left
side the left side is going to be the
side opposite the completed side so the
completed side is always going to go on
the right when you're doing this move
here there is a reverse Allen it's just
basically with this side on the left and
you do it the right side first instead
of the left side but we're not going to
go over that one here I think it's just
easier to memorize this one first and
then you
switch it on your own okay so what it
actually does is with this on the right
side the completed side it rotates these
three edge pieces in a counterclockwise
direction so if you look at the color
this red edge piece is going to be put
on the side that is over all red except
for the exception of that the green
piece there this green piece is going to
be put on the green side and the orange
piece is going to be put on the orange
side so you can tell that by rotating
these three pieces you will have a
complete cube so let's go ahead and do
that move okay so you want to just be
sure that you have the completed side on
the right so holding that on the right
you're going to do left 180 degrees top
face counterclockwise now when you're
doing the back face clockwise it does
not go like this what you actually have
to be doing when you're doing the back
face counterclockwise is you have to
look at the face directly and when
you're looking at the face directly if
you're going to do it clockwise it would
be going to the right like so okay so
that's back face clockwise the next move
after that is front face
counterclockwise okay then we again do
the left 180 then we do the back face
which is red counterclockwise the front
face clockwise then the top face goes
counterclockwise and for the last move
to finish up the cube left face 180
degrees and as you can see if you had a
cube that was very similar to that you
should have a completed cube now there
is an exception if you didn't have a
color here in this middle edge piece
that was on the opposite side so if this
piece that you see in front of you is
wasn't orange
and you had the blue on the right then
it wouldn't complete the cube so if we
take a look at this one this one has
four sides which have one edge piece
that is improper so if we perform the
move here and you're looking at this
piece that's blue well that blue piece
is going to be put on the orange side
and the green is going to be put on the
blue red is going to be put on the red
so after we finish this move the red
side is going to be the side that is
going to be completed so left side 180
top counterclockwise back face clockwise
front face counterclockwise left side
180 back face counterclockwise front
face clockwise top counterclockwise and
left face 180 degrees okay so now you
see that the red face is the face that
is complete and now what you would want
to do with that is put that on the right
so if we do that and we complete the
move you'll see that this is this piece
that is green well we put on the green
side the piece that's orange will be
foot on the orange side and the piece
that's blue will be put on the blue side
so you will have a completed tube after
you finish so left side 180 top
counterclockwise back face clockwise
front face counterclockwise left face
180 back counterclockwise front
clockwise top
counterclockwise and left face 180
degrees now if you do that move and your
cube is still not complete if you still
have three three edge pieces that are in
improper positions all you have to do is
just hold that solid side that is
completed on the right always and you
might have to repeat that move I think
maximum three times so if you have to do
it more than three times and your cube
does not look complete then you are
possibly doing one of the moves wrong
just be sure to write that down and be
sure that you're doing all the moves
properly your cube should at least have
just those three edges if you see any
other colors in the top layer like white
or any other colors from the side or if
the bottom looks messed up then you
might have done one of these steps wrong
so just be sure those back ones are
pretty tricky because I know a lot of
people that I've tried to help solve a
cube they did it backwards and it messed
up the cube and they thought I gave them
the wrong algorithm but this is the
proper algorithm so it's left 180 top
counterclockwise back clockwise front
counterclockwise left 180 back
counterclockwise front clockwise top
counterclockwise and left 180 okay guys
so I hope that you did find the tutorial
helpful and that you got a solved
Rubik's Cube in front of you if you had
any problems at all just send me
messages on YouTube and I'll be happy to
help you out if I can alright guys so
hope you enjoyed it